da haben ist luca der liebe freunde ich
darf euch heute herzlich willkommen
heißen endlich wieder zu einer neuen
episode trägt schuster ich würde sagen
so wie es immer der fall starten wir
heute wieder mit dem westen tik tok der
woche sagen wir kannst du mal kurz den
samt geben und auch noch das wasser
betrifft ja also ich würde auf jeden
fall mal auf trägt auch beim user laser
luca vorbeischoss
er hat nun allerdings auch mit dem
ersten richtigen job der heutigen
episode tik tok tuesday und zwar ist es
ein reh das in japan über einen
zebrastreifen gehen will ja fragt
einfach nicht
[Applaus]
das reh beherrscht die
straßenverkehrsregeln besser als manch
deutscher beim nächsten tag doch video
haben vier mädchen jeder ein paar
kopfhörer mit extrem lauter musik auf
die versuchen sich gegenseitig etwas zu
sagen an die gäste
das hat ziemlich gut geklappt
[Musik]
das nächste tik tok mache ich jetzt
einfach mal live mit denn man soll
nachdem man die übungen gemacht hat
angeblich nicht mehr reden können
hallo mein name ist korrekt danke das
hab ich mich schon mein leben lang
gefragt am nächsten tag doch versuchen
zwei jungs am essener hauptbahnhof etwas
aus einem süßigkeiten automaten
kostenlos rauszubekommen
doch dann kommen nachher mitarbeiter der
deutschen bahn entweder war selbst noch
nicht
ich habe schon gesehen dass er dahin wie
ein vater für höheres
hey
wir wünschen euch dabei wir versuchen
etwas kostenlos aus den
süßigkeitenautomaten zu bekommen und
damit 70 30 kite die noch zu fragen um
ihnen kostenlose fahrkarte bekommt
menschen nicht gesehen ziemlich abstoßen
nächste person hat gerade ein loch
gestand bekommen und bekommt dann einen
spiegel gereicht weil sie sich das ganze
anschauen will und schaut einfach
[Musik]
ja
herzlich willkommen zur weiteren episode
lokal klatscht obwohl ballack so die
wahrheit kennt ihr das im unterricht
sitzen damit eure besten freund oder
eurer besten der welt und könnte einfach
nicht aufhören
stellt euch vor ihr spielt in eurem
zimmer und dann ruft eure mutter von
unten aus der küche komm mal runter
auf dem halben weg die treppe runter
hört ihr eure mutter ist im schlafzimmer
rufen nicht runter ich habe es
aufgegangen was tut mir einmal dürft ihr
raten wer sich das tik tok nachts um 3
uhr angeschaut hat
richtig ich will es nicht sagen aber es
ist die wahrheit eine freundin von mir
damals in der grundschule durch dieses
suchen einfach aquarium zerstört
[Musik]
so häufig
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das war einfach die weltweit größte
feuerwerksrakete war der typ dann
einfach mit plastikbechern der pyramide
gebaut und das schlafen gegangen und hat
seine ganzen schlaf über einen
livestream gemacht ja ich habe eine
stunde lang zugeschaut
hallo meine freunde der nächste song
heißt wahrheit
[Musik]
dieser ist in der regel da
die das nicht an seinen an seinen füßen
schon erkennen müssen ist mein manager
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja
die idee aller zeiten die gabe von fag
ich habe mit sandra versucht das ticket
zu regieren allerdings happig seiner
nicht hochheben können mich am arsch
was bekomme ich für ein schwachsinn auf
meiner homepage
egal ob sagt zumindest die triebe street
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich weiß keiner mark angeber man sieht
auf jeden fall diesen hund dich liebt
[Musik]
aus sonder- und ich bin damals nach ok
walter
[Musik]
kann ich sagen daß dir du bist mit
seinem rad 210 wahrheit
merkel braucht man dazu nicht sagen okay
das war sehr befreiend
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich kann nicht mal alle mädchen spielen
keiner suchten die so einfach nicht ist
die kuppel nicht immer
wenn ich auf den krieg mir dass uns ein
video fand ich nicht hoffen
[Musik]
ja das enkheim die eine richtung gemacht
und durch den schlag von dem kissen
seiner freundin ist die bruder mützen
sind ab jetzt seine allerbesten freunde
sag mir wer denkt freund ist und ich
sage dir wer du bist werden krank ist
oder du bist
wow
ist eigentlich recht kreativ so gab wie
kommt man auf so einen schwachsinn bei
der feuerwehr ist für beide strecken
fahren erzählt ich sagen meine lieben
freunde aber es ist einfach die wahrheit
warum können hunde nicht ganz normal
einfach sagen hey hey langsam vorbei
aber die müssen wir so komplett ausraste
und ausland halten paar roadster zwar
ansteigen an der schändliche hat die
episode zeigt doch dass jetzt eine stop
and meine lieben freunde wenn es euch
gefallen hat das gerne einen daumen hoch
oder video da ich als ob die gläser
lokal sofort mit auch gerne schreibt mir
euren ticketeinnahmen gehen und die
kommentare wenn ihr in die nächste wieso
das heck topteams nächste woche dienstag
rein kommen wollte
und jetzt habe ich sogar noch ein tipp
für euch und zwar von einer kellnerin
die wunderschön happy birthday zu einem
kunden sinkt
[Musik]